and missy starts tearing everybody's new
one because her little boyfriend broke
up with her
poor thing but good training for when
her husband dumps her one day
i'm sorry about that no you know what
the truth is it was over a while ago
it happens
but hey
he's got the kids tonight and ladies
drink half price so let's pretend i'm a
lady
yes ma'am
you look like you could use a shot with
that beard
i got school in the morning oh
i didn't realize we were both here for
ladies night
can we get some shots over here
you were a cheerleader yeah i mean you
wouldn't know it to look at me now don't
say that i can totally see on top of
that pyramid oh i was on the bottom and
you know it
but at least i could fill out a sweater
you and me both sisters
i love skinner you know what i saw them
play dallas
you can will you i just got kicked out
of beauty school
so i guess
76
i was at that show stop it
nazareth open oh my god they did
they did small world yeah
you won't dance
me no oh come on i know
there's
people here
if we go someplace else
well you have in mind
russell does have the kids
oh god i'm sorry
that was that was over the line
you okay
george
[Music]
brenda
have you heard anything not yet
oh what happened um i ran into george at
the bar
and
next thing i know he started having
chest pains
thank the lord you were there with him
oh
i really
didn't do anything don't say that who
knows what would have happened if you
haven't been there
hi
mary wanted to send over some food since
you weren't feeling well
thank you
can we talk a minute
welcome i'm sorry about earlier
it's okay
i understand so i want this to be weird
we're neighbors you don't know why for
friends your kids aren't here right
no
we're neighbors you and my wife are
friends that's why it's weird george but
nothing actually happened
there's no reason to feel guilty
okay
i mean do we have too much to drink sure
did we talk about going home from the
bar together okay i'm sorry about that
don't need to apologize because we
didn't go
all we did was have a nice time in a
public place
there anything wrong with that
kind of feels like it does feel like it
what's it feel like
maybe
because it was nice to talk to someone
and feel special
it was
maybe you should go i should go
thanks for stopping by yeah all right
[Music]
you